(light cheery music)
Well, it's time to share
some home-cooked pasta
with someone I don't get
to see enough these days,
my friend, Andy Richter.
Hey, Andy!
Hey Conan, it's great to be here
sitting exactly six feet across from you.
So what are we sharing today?
Well today, Andy, we're sharing a classic.
Spaghetti and meatballs
topped with Prego pasta sauce.
Ooh, that looks good, but why
did you specifically mention
the brand of pasta sauce?
You mean, Prego pasta sauce?
No reason.
Now, let's dig in.
Oh wow, that sauce is really thick.
I can't wait to try it.
This is the traditional
way to serve spaghetti.
Here, let me show you how a pro does it.
(eating)
Oh, that Prego is so good.
Prego! (laughs)
I like where this is going.
(bleep)
Whew!
Ugh, well thanks for the meal, pal.
You're welcome.
Or as they say in
Italian, Prego (chuckles).
Why do you always have
to make it about them?
You know, I have feeling t--
[Voiceover] Prego.
It means you're welcome.